veamos el mecanismo de reacción de una
reacción de eliminación e1 vamos a
empezar aquí en la izquierda con nuestro
sustrato y digamos que este es un alumno
de alquilo entonces el carbono que está
enlazado con nuestro halógeno es el
carbono alfa y el carbono que está a su
lado es un carbono beta ok necesitamos
un carbono beta para que suceda esta
reacción necesitamos a este hidrógeno
beta ahora el primer paso para las
reacciones de eliminación en uno es la
pérdida del grupo saliente entonces
estamos escribiendo por aquí que el
primer paso de las reacciones en uno es
la pérdida del grupo saliente así es que
qué es lo que está pasando por acá bueno
pues que los electrones de este enlace
se van con el grupo saliente en el
primer paso de la reacción entonces lo
que está sucediendo aquí es
este carbono el carbono alfa pierde un
enlace este carbono está pasando de
tener una hibridación sp3 a tener una
hibridación sp2 por lo que ahora tenemos
un kart vocaciòn los carbó cationes los
carbonos ibiza 2 sp2 sabemos que tienen
una geometría plana y esto es lo que
estoy tratando de mostrar poniendo estos
enlaces de esta forma bueno este es el
primer paso la pérdida del grupo
saliente que provoca la formación de un
kart vocación ahora en el segundo paso
llega a una base y se lleva a este
protón dejando a sus electrones para que
formen un doble enlace y así se forma un
al que no entonces en esta segunda parte
de la reacción la base toma uno de los
protones y se forma el al que no vamos a
seguir de cerca el movimiento de estos
electrones estos electrones de éste
si se mueven para acá formando el doble
enlace y así se forma nuestro producto
final el al que no ahora este paso la
pérdida del grupo saliente es el paso
limitante de la velocidad es el paso más
lento de todo el mecanismo de reacción
si estás escribiendo una ecuación de
velocidad la velocidad va a ser igual a
una constante por la concentración del
sustrato eso es lo que han mostrado los
estudios que la velocidad de este tipo
de reacciones depende únicamente de la
concentración del sustrato así es que es
una reacción de primer orden con
respecto al sustrato y eso se debe por
este paso el límite de velocidad porque
la pérdida del grupo saliente es el paso
límite de la velocidad entonces lo que
realmente importa para la velocidad es
la concentración del sustrato la base no
puede hacer absolutamente nada
hasta que el grupo saliente se desenlace
de la molécula la base no participa en
el paso límite de la velocidad participa
únicamente en el segundo paso de la
reacción
entonces la concentración de la base no
afecta la velocidad con la que sucede la
reacción lo único que sí afecta a la
velocidad de la reacción es la
concentración del sustrato ahora como
esta reacción depende únicamente de la
concentración del sustrato decimos que
es una reacción de eliminación e1 donde
aquí la parte del 1 se refiere a que
tiene una ecuación de velocidad 1
molecular y bueno la parte de la iv se
refiere a que es una reacción de
eliminación es una reacción de
eliminación y es una reacción un y
molecular eso lo que nos dice es que la
ecuación de la velocidad depende
únicamente de la concentración de una
molécula del sustrato
entonces si aumentamos la concentración
del sustrato ok si aumentamos la
concentración del sustrato si le
aumentamos digamos por un factor de 2
entonces también vamos a estar
aumentando la velocidad de la reacción
por un factor 2 ok y aquí decimos que es
una reacción de primer orden con
respecto al sustrato esto es un poco de
química general pero bueno por otro lado
si aumentamos la concentración de la
base por 2 no vamos a obtener ningún
cambio en la velocidad de la reacción
ahora hay un detalle más acerca de esta
reacción que tenemos que considerar
la formación de este carbón como tenemos
un kart vocación en este mecanismo de
reacción tenemos que considerar la
posibilidad de una reestructuración y
también tenemos que pensar en qué
substrato produce un kart vocación
estable por ejemplo un sustrato
terciario que forme un kart boquete un
terciario que es más estable favorece a
un mecanismo de reacción e1 bueno vamos
a ver un ejemplo de esto
aquí tenemos un alumno de alquilo
terciario y digamos que este al duro de
alquilo sufre una reacción de
eliminación y uno por aquí el carbono
que está enlazado con el átomo de yodo
debe de ser nuestro carbono alfa y luego
tenemos 3 carbonos beta
este es un carbono beta este también es
un carbono beta y este también es un
carbono beta el primer paso en nuestra
reacción de eliminación y 1 es la
pérdida del grupo saliente si dibujamos
los pares de electrones libres de este
átomo de yodo nos queda así pero sabemos
que los electrones del enlace se van a
quedar en el yodo formando una unión de
yodo tenemos por aquí un unión de yodo
que tiene una carga negativa y
resaltando estos electrones pasan de
este enlace al unión de yodo y se quedan
aquí y ahora
es un excelente grupo saliente y podemos
saber eso consultando su valor pk a alan
jon de yodo es la base con jugada de un
ácido muy fuerte que tiene un valor de
pk
de aproximadamente menos 11 entonces
esto lo que nos dice es que h y es muy
bueno donando un protón por lo que es su
base conjugada debe de ser muy estable y
eso hace que la unión de yodo sea un
grupo saliente muy estable pero bueno si
perdemos este átomo de yodo eso hace que
este carbono pierda un par de electrones
y se vuelva un kart vocaciòn lo vamos a
dibujar por acá tenemos aquí un kart
vocaciòn este carbono se transforma en
éste carbó catión y tiene una carga
formal positiva porque perdió un enlace
entonces este es el primer paso de una
reacción de eliminación y uno
en el segundo paso lo que sucede es que
llega a una base y se lleva un protón de
alguno de los carbonos beta en esta
reacción esta base es etanol y vamos a
empezar por aquí dibujando los pares de
electrones libres de este oxígeno por
cierto también hay que tomar en cuenta
que estamos aplicando calor en esta
reacción y bueno el etanol aquí está
funcionando como una base no es una base
muy fuerte pero si puede llegar y
llevarse algún protón vamos a dibujar lo
paso por paso por aquí este carbono
tiene varios hidrógenos pero nada más
vamos a dibujar uno ahora
estabas te llega y se lleva a este
protón ahora un par de electrones del
oxígeno de esta base llega y se lleva a
este hidrógeno y entonces los electrones
de este enlace se quedan aquí formando
un doble enlace y por lo tanto formando
un al que no si dibujamos por acá
nuestro producto nos queda algo así y
acá los electrones que estaban formando
este enlace
ahora están formando un enlace doble
ahora hay algunos puntos acerca de esta
reacción que tenemos que ver uno de esos
puntos que nos falta ver es que en los
mecanismos de reacción sn 1 el primer
paso es que un grupo saliente se va
formándose un carbó catión exactamente
igual a lo que tenemos aquí ahora ya que
nos encontramos en esta situación con
éste carbó catión tal vez nos podemos
preguntar
y aquí el etanol está funcionando como
base no podría también funcionar como
núcleo filo y la respuesta es que el
etanol definitivamente puede actuar como
un núcleo filo y si hiciera eso actuar
como núcleo filo atacaría al carbono con
carga positiva y entonces el producto
que obtendríamos sería el de una
sustitución así es que si el etanol
actúa como un núcleo filo lo que
obtenemos es un mecanismo de reacción de
sustitución sn 1 pero por otro lado si
el etanol actúa como una base obtenemos
un mecanismo de reacción de eliminación
e1 pero bueno en este vídeo nos vamos a
enfocar en el mecanismo de reacción de
eliminación y no en el de sustitución
pero definitivamente vamos a volver a
hablar de estas cosas en un vídeo más
adelante porque en una reacción como
esta puede suceder cualquiera de las dos
cosas pero bueno hay otra cosa de la que
quiero que hablemos en
sustrato tenemos 3 carbonos beta y yo
simplemente escogí uno de estos carbonos
este carbono y decidí que el etanol
tomaba un protón de este carbono pero en
este caso realmente no importa de qué
carbono tomamos el protón porque en este
caso hay simetría aunque hay digamos que
estamos en este punto donde tenemos aquí
a nuestro carbó catión pero ahora le
vamos a quitar un protón a este carbono
porque ahí aquí tenemos un hidrógeno
entonces llega a nuestra base débil y
toma este protón los electrones de este
enlace se van para acá y nos queda
exactamente el mismo producto
ok nos queda aquí tenemos esto a ver
vamos a ver a dónde se fueron los
electrones los electrones de este enlace
fueron a dar por acá formando este doble
enlace pero es
es el mismo producto que tenemos por acá
y sucede exactamente lo mismo si le
quitamos un protón al otro carbono beta
ahora veamos otro ejemplo los alcoholes
también pueden participar en un
mecanismo de reacción de eliminación e1
el carbono que está enlazado con el
grupo h es el carbono alfa y este
carbono que se encuentra cerca de él
sería el carbono beta haciendo
reaccionar nuestro alcohol con ácido
sulfúrico y aplicándole calor a la
reacción nos da como producto un al que
no algunas veces también se utiliza el
ácido fosfórico en lugar del ácido
sulfúrico ahora ya vimos que el primer
paso de una reacción de eliminación en
uno es la pérdida del grupo saliente
pero si eso sucediera en esta reacción
si los electrones de este enlace se
fueran con el oxígeno eso formaría unión
hidróxido este sería nuestro grupo
saliente
o el hidróxido es un grupo saliente muy
pobre y por supuesto sabemos eso
observando los valores pk
por acá tenemos el avión hidróxido que
es la base conjugada del agua pero el
agua no es un ácido muy fuerte eso es
justo lo que nos está diciendo su valor
de pk
por acá el agua no es muy buena
donando un protón lo cual significa que
el a nyon hidróxido no es muy estable
eso provoca que no sea un buen grupo
saliente entonces tenemos que venir por
acá y borrar esta flechita porque el año
en hidróxido no es un buen grupo
saliente y entonces la pérdida de este
grupo hidróxido no es el primer paso de
esta reacción el primer paso en este
caso es una transferencia de protón
tenemos un ácido muy fuerte por acá el
ácido sulfúrico y el alcohol va a
funcionar como una base tomando un
protón del ácido sulfúrico
y lo que hace es que el grupo saliente
sea una molécula de agua y el agua si es
un muy buen grupo saliente sobre todo en
comparación con el año ni hidróxido y
claro podemos saber eso por sus valores
pk a el agua es la base conjugada del
ácido y drone yo hace tres o más y como
es muy bueno
donando uno de sus protones por eso
tiene un valor de pk
más bajo y eso también provoca que su
base conjugada el agua sea estable pero
bueno regresando a la reacción cuando
tenemos una reacción de eliminación en
uno con un alcohol justo por esto que
acabamos de ver el primer paso es
proponer al grupo
h pero bueno veamos una reacción de
ácido sulfúrico con un alcohol con más
espacio por aquí tenemos nuestro alcohol
y el carbono enlazado con el oxígeno es
nuestro carbono alfa todos estos
carbonos enlazados con nuestro
alfa son carbonos beta ahora lo que
acabamos de ver es que el primer paso en
el mecanismo de reacción es 1 cuando
tenemos un alcohol es la transferencia
de un protón un par de electrones libres
llegan y se llevan uno de los protones
del ácido sulfúrico aunque hay estos
electrones se quedan en el oxígeno del
ácido sulfúrico así es que acabamos de
transferir un protón y lo que nos queda
es esto donde este oxígeno tiene una
carga positiva pero a ver vamos a ver
qué sucedió con los electrones estos dos
electrones fueron y tomaron este protón
formando este enlace y ahora lo que
tenemos como grupo saliente es una
molécula de agua y estos electrones de
este enlace pueden quedarse en el
oxígeno eso nos da una molécula de agua
como nuestro grupo saliente y otra vez
veamos qué pasa con los electrones los
electrones de este
en la cee se quedaron como un par de
electrones libres en el oxígeno que
ahora forman parte de una molécula de
agua que es nuestro grupo saliente y por
cierto es un muy buen grupo saliente
ahora por otro lado cuando estos
electrones se quedaron con el oxígeno le
quitamos un enlace a este carbono de
rojo y entonces se volvió en khar
vocación y vamos a dibujarlo por acá
aquí tenemos a nuestro carbó catión este
carbono que tiene una carga formal
positiva pero ahora el siguiente paso de
la reacción es que llega a una base y se
lleva uno de los protones de los
carbonos beta digamos que se lleva un
protón de este carbono así es que por
aquí vamos a dibujar a ese protón y voy
a dibujar una base genérica que llega y
se lleva a este protón y entonces los
electrones que estaban formando este
enlace vienen para acá a formar un doble
enlace entre estos dos carbonos y así
y es como se forma nuestro producto y
otra vez vamos a ver qué pasó con los
electrones los electrones de este enlace
se movieron para acá o sea para acá
formando nuestro al que no pero bueno
por aquí puse una base genérica ahorita
vamos a hablar un poco más acerca de
esta base algunas veces vamos a ver a
moléculas de agua actuando como esta
base algunas otras es hs o 4 - la base
con jugada del ácido sulfúrico algunos
libros de texto usan una opción algunos
libros de texto usan la otra yo no creo
que realmente importe mucho
alguna de estas moléculas actúa como la
base débil así es que tal vez el agua
llega y actúa como esta base débil y se
lleva uno de estos protones provocando
la formación de este al que no y por eso
a veces a esta reacción se le llama una
reacción de deshidratación porque
estamos perdiendo agua en el proceso